А тепер в ефірі «heute journal».
Англія - нова чемпіонка Європи.
На стадіоні «Вемблі» німецькі футболістки
програли Англії у напруженому фіналі.
Шкода, звісно, однак бажаємо
німецькій команді перемог у майбутньому,
а вам, шановні глядачі, гарного недільного вечора.
Цей вечір, безперечно, чудовий для англійської збірної
та її вболівальників.
Адже вперше за останні 56 років
жінки здобули міжнародний титул.
І це сталось саме там,
де Англія здобула світове чемпіонство в 1966 році,
на переповненому легендарному стадіоні «Вемблі».
Це був турнір з величезною глядацькою підтримкою,
очевидно, бальзам
для стурбованих душ мільйонів
футбольних уболівальників.
Фотографії та реакції цього
животрепетного футбольного вечора
покаже нам Марсель Берґман.
Гідний вечір для завершення Чемпіонату Європи,
у якому господарки поля здобули перемогу.
Як і в 1966 році, матч завершився овертаймом,
і Німеччина посіла друге місце.
Звичайно, ми розчаровані,
що не зуміли перемогти,
ми хотіли зіграти якнайкраще,
але, на жаль, не впоралися,
тому так, ми розчаровані.
Ми не можемо себе звинувачувати,
хоча й розчаровані,
можна підсумувати,
що ми зіграли дійсно хороший матч.
Склад збірної Англії незмінний вже вшосте,
тим часом збірній Німеччині
довелось замінити
не лише Клару Бюль, хвору на коронавірус,
а й травмовану Александру Попп.
Від самого початку гра була напруженою,
на 29 хвилині Геґерінґ робить удар,
однак м'яч перехоплює воротарка.
Використання рук вартує пенальті.
На 38-ій хвилині Еллен Вайт наважується
на прямий удар, м'яч пролітає над воротами.
В першому таймі не забито жодного голу,
але потім Волш пасує
зі своєї половини поля,
гравчиня тільки-но вийшла на заміну
і забиває м'яч прямісінько у ліві ворота.
Англійська збірна попереду
через годину після початку гри.
Буквально через чотири хвилини -
шанс зрівняти рахунок,
Ліна Магулль б'є праворуч,
м'яч відлітає від воріт.
На 79-й хвилині пас Ломан у штрафний майданчик,
Васмут передає м'яч Магулль і та замикає ближню штангу, гол!
Рахунок зрівняно, 1:1!
Потім овертайм, і на 111-й хвилині
кутовий м'яч відскакує
до Келлі, яка поцілює його у ворота.
Гол на користь англійської збірної!
Після вирішального удару
Хлоя Келлі на емоціях зняла футболку.
Для обох збірних закінчився неймовірно
насичений Чемпіонат Європи,
після якого у жіночого футболу з'явилось
ще більше прихильників.
Який насичений вечір,
перепрошую, що на початку ми переплутали
Генріх та Фромс.
Наша репортерка Катя Штрезо побувала на матчі,
Скажи, будь ласка, як ти сприйняла тріумф і поразку
на легендарному «Вемблі»?
Це було неймовірно,
стільки людей очікувало на фінал.
Крім того, німецька збірна була змушена
тимчасово замінити Александру Попп,
до того ж у найкоротший термін.
Маю визнати, її тут дійсно бракувало.
Хочу зробити комплімент збірній
Мартіни Фосс-Текленбурґ,
яка гідно грала до останньої секунди,
не гірше за англійську збірну.
Зрештою перемогла не найкраща команда,
а та, якій трохи більше пощастило.
Це спорт.
Катю, тепер про результат Чемпіонату.
Хочеш того чи ні,
жінок весь час порівнюють із чоловіками.
Як вважаєш, чи допоміг цей ЧЄ
переосмислити жіночий футбол?
Думаю, так, значною мірою.
Це можна побачити завдяки
сприйняттю аудиторії в Німеччині,
адже таких високих рейтингів,
як зараз у жіночому футболі, ще не було.
Так треба тримати і далі,
збірна надихнула своєю чудовою грою.
Вона грала так, як ніхто не очікував.
Гравчині були на полі як одне ціле,
і цей гайп, який вони створили,
треба підтримувати і надалі.
Тренерка збірної
Мартіна Фосс-Текленбурґ наголосила,
що ми мусимо зробити жіночий футбол резонансним.
Йдеться насамперед про сприйняття,
тобто жіночий футбол
має сприйматися не гірше,
а таким професійним, як і чоловічий.
Це стосується тренерів, умов тренувань та змагань.
Це важкий і тернистий шлях,
однак це мета, до якої прагне Німеччина.
Так, як це вже раніше зробили Англія і Франція.
Щиро дякую, це була Катя Штрезо з Лондона.
Тепер до теми, яку не можна оминути.
Від насиченої футбольної події
перейдімо до війни в Україні,
де Росія не припиняє масовані обстріли
Півдня та Сходу країни.
Що ж до вивозу зерна з портів Чорного моря
та низки супровідних сумнівів,
турецька влада сьогодні  висловила сподівання,
що експорт може розпочатися вже завтра.
Глави урядів Росії та України
нещодавно виступили з насиченими промовами.
Президент Зеленський закликав жителів
Донецького регіону
негайно покинути територію області,
а Володимир Путін знову висловив погрози у бік Заходу
під час виступу у Санкт-Петербурзі.
Більше розкаже Камран Сафяріан.
Я вітаю вас
з Днем Військово-Морських Сил.
Так виглядає сьогоднішня демонстрація сили
Путіна у Санкт-Петербурзі.
День відзначається у всій країні.
Цим користується лідер Кремля,
щоб кинути Заходу новий заклик до бою.
З новою морською доктриною.
За цією доктриною, США і НАТО вважаються
найбільшою загрозою для Росії.
Ми будемо захищати
наші морські кордони
усіма доступними способами.
При цьому потужність російського флоту -
це найголовніше.
Він здатен
блискавично реагувати на всіх,
хто хоче втрутитися
в наш суверенітет і волю.
Жодним словом не згадав
Путін за війну в Україні.
До того ж він погрожує новою зброєю.
Буде достатньо, якщо я стисло згадаю
нову систему гіперзвукової ракети «Циркон».
Вона унікальна, для неї не існує перешкод.
Святкування на базі російського
Чорноморського флоту
у Севастополі, навпаки, скасовується.
Росія стверджує, що винна атака безпілотників,
яку ініціювала Україна.
Україна це заперечує
і говорить про провокацію.
Сьогодні знову бої та обстріли
в багатьох регіонах України,
як і тут,
у другому за величиною місті - Харкові.
Через російські атаки президент України
закликав жителів Донецької області
покинути територію області.
На Донбасі мешкають сотні тисяч
людей, зокрема, тисячі дітей.
Багато жителів не хочуть покидати домівки.
Будь ласка, зробіть це зараз.
Адже чим більше
людей залишає Донецьку область,
тим менше
може вбити російська армія.
158-ий день війни в Україні,
російські ігри мускулами
і жодної перспективи миру.
Що буває, коли партія відходить від своєї суті,
можна було побачити на прикладі SPD.
Відповідно до реформ Agenda 2010
і масштабних змін у соціальному законодавстві
криза тривала аж до останніх загальних виборів.
І що відбувається
зараз із партією Зелених?
Ще пів року тому
вони виступали проти поставок зброї.
Запуск вугільних електростанцій
та пошук сумнівних угод з партнерами,
де права людини мають менше значення, -
усе це теж не було передбачено програмою Зелених.
Сюди ж віднесемо неоднозначні позиціонування
щодо подовження терміну експлуатації АЕС.
Про зміни в партії Зелених та
енергетичну суперечку в «світлофорній» коаліції
розповіла сьогодні лідерка Зелених
в «Літньому інтерв'ю ZDF».
Томас Райхарт розповість детальніше.
У розмові стабільно фігурує ще одна особа,
яка нібо незримо присутня на інтерв'ю.
Під час цього діалогу з лідеркою партії Зелених
це Крістіан Лінднер.
В газетному інтерв'ю він вимагає
продовження використання атомних електростанцій
до 2024 року.
Конфлікт в «світлофорній» коаліції
тепер дійшов до громадськості.
Коли Ви припините
опір подовженню експлуатації
атомних електростанцій?
Мета Крістіана Лінднера -
не що інше, як повернення до атомної енергетики.
Ми цього не дозволимо.
Поки Ланґ виступає в Дюссельдорфі,
Лінднер перед камерами в Берліні
знову порушує вже закриту тему.
Зараз у нас безпечно працюють атомні електростанції.
Ми маємо заощаджувати газ,
ми не можемо використовувати
його для виробництва електроенергії.
Тож цілком доцільним
і технічно можливим є використання
вже наявних системи ще деякий час.
Ланґ, зі свого боку, звинувачує Лінднера у «несерйозних дебатах».
Атомна енергетика навряд чи допоможе
замінити відсутній російський газ.
Справа в тому, що газові електростанції в Німеччині
дуже мало використовуються для виробництва електроенергії.
Тому атомною енергетикою можна замінити
лише мізерну частину газу.
Ми маємо проблеми з опаленням, а не з електроенергією.
Через високі ціни на електроенергію
Ланґ закликає до подальших фінансових полегшень
для людей з низькими доходами.
Фінансуватиметься це, наприклад,
за рахунок податку на надприбуток енергетичних компаній,
які зараз отримують значно вищий дохід.
Знову протиріччя з боку Лінднера.
Ми маємо утриматись від усього,
що ставить під загрозу робочі місця,
економічний розвиток і довіру до Німеччини як до бізнес-партнера.
Ми маємо зробити все можливе,
щоб захистити людей від інфляції та усунути її причини.
В цьому наші цілі збігаються.
Але шляхи вирішення цього можуть бути різні.
Суперечка стосується ядра коаліції:
Зелені отримали найбільшу популярність,
але були змушені поступитися.
З FDP все з точністю до навпаки.
Зараз Зелені зазнають тиску з боку
громадян та колишніх членів партії.
Крістіан Штребеле, наприклад, запитує про екологічність
політичних рішень з огляду на поставки зброї
та подовження терміну експлуатації АЕС:
«Коли впаде наступний стовп? Аби цього не сталось».
Ланґ в ефірі ZDF закликає FDP і SPD піти на поступки.
Якщо ми, Зелені, увійшли в уряд
із закликом щодо захисту клімату
і тепер дозволяємо вугільним електростанціям
працювати довше, це все ускладнює.
Якщо FDP бере на себе міністерство фінансів,
а потім все більше
ставить під сумнів реальність
«боргового гальма», це все ускладнює.
Але я вважаю,
що усі мають бути готовими
перестрибнути через власну тінь.
Я очікую цього від партнера коаліції.
Найпізніше до кінця літа їм доведеться вирішити суперечку,
адже їм ще фактично
сидіти за одним столом в уряді.
Цей рік важкий для тих,
хто планує подорожувати літаком.
Авіакомпанія Lufthansa та її пасажири
мають підготуватися до ще одного можливого страйку,
детальніше розповість Ґундула.
Хороша новина полягає в тому,
що страйку, за який проголосували пілоти профспілки Cockpit,
можна уникнути.
Хоча відповідна заява ще не оприлюднена.
Незважаючи на те, що більшість пілотів Lufthansa
проголосувала за страйк,
метою все ж є посилення переговорної позиції
в конфлікті щодо заробітної плати,
який зайшов у глухий кут.
Пілоти вимагають підвищення зарплати на 5,5%,
автоматичної індексації
та коригування тарифної структури.
В Ірані кількість загиблих унаслідок сильних штормів
зросла щонайменше до 69 осіб,
багато людей досі вважаються зниклими безвісти.
Сильні дощі спричинили повені
в 24 із 31 провінцій.
За даними органів влади, 37 тис. людей
залишилися без даху над головою.
Найближчими днями очікуються подальші шторми.
На колишній залізниці Buchenwaldbahn поблизу Веймара
були закладені
меморіальні камені вбитим єврейським юнакам та дівчатам.
У 1944 році вони були депортовані націонал-соціалістами
саме цим маршрутом
з концентраційного табору
«Бухенвальд» до табору «Аушвіц».
111 пам’ятних каменів, які зараз
закладено, вшановують пам’ять жертв.
Все це відбувається в межах проєкту «Культура пам'яті».
Спікер Палати представників Конгресу США Ненсі Пелосі,
сьогодні вирушає з візитом до Азії.
Раніше вона анонсувала, що разом із делегацією відвідає
Сінгапур, Малайзію, Південну Корею та Японію.
Про поїздку до Тайваню вона не згадала.
Припущення щодо візиту Пелосі на Тайвань
додають напруги у відносини між США та Китаєм.
Пекін принципово відкидає візити іноземних політиків
до вільного Тайваню,
вбачаючи в цьому підтвердження його фактичної незалежності.
Китай надалі погрожує завоювати Тайвань.
Тож не є випадковістю й те, що Китай
вчора провів маневр із застосуванням
боєприпасів поблизу Тайваню.
У будь-якому разі західним демократіям
стає все важче взаємодіяти з «Піднебесною».
Де провести межу між вигідними угодами
та небезпечною залежністю
від автократично керованої країни? -
питання, яке тривожить Німеччину та інші країни
протягом тривалого часу,
а ще більше - після початку війни в Україні.
За останні 20 років
Китай досяг приголомшливого зростання.
Середньорічна заробітна плата працівників за цей період
зросла в десятки разів.
З приходом до влади в 2013 році президента Сі
зовнішня політика стала агресивнішою,
внутрішня - авторитарнішою.
Детальніше про прагнення до влади
та людину, яка могла б правити до 2030-х - Ульф Роллер.
Він малює тих, хто визначав і визначає долю Китаю.
Фото для підручників з історії.
Пензель Чжан Цзяньбіня шукає величі в людях.
Мао Цзедун, колишній президент КНР,
панував над усіма його послідовниками.
Тепер хтось інший наслідує його шлях.
Сі також хоче стати вічним президентом.
Тому мистецтво Чжан Цзяньбіня може викликати
лише захоплення і жодних сумнівів.
Я хочу намалювати президента Сі
як людину, близьку до народу.
Його клієнти - віддані партійці
та заможні підприємці.
Багато хто хоче, щоб портрет Сі висів у них вдома,
адже поклоніння захищає.
Сі не тільки одягнув костюм Мао
на святкування 100-річчя партії,
він також хоче абсолютної влади, як Мао,
щоб народ служив йому.
Якою буде спадщина президента Сі?
О, я не можу судити про це.
Він дозволяє  називати себе «дядьком Сі»
і представляє себе народним трибуном,
особливо під час його візиту до Сіньцзяну.
Уйгури, пригноблена мусульманська меншина,
змушені танцювати.
Сі визначає, хто належить Китаю.
Кожен, хто має поруч іншого бога, потрапляє в табір.
Йдеться про правий популістський націоналізм.
Це відповідає тенденції, яку ми спостерігаємо в усьому світі
протягом останнього десятиліття,
наприклад, з Путіним і Ердоганом.
Сі вважає себе лідером комуністичного світу.
Альянс із Путіним - це новий світовий порядок.
Сі хоче об'єднати демократичний острів Тайвань
з материковим Китаєм,
використовуючи в разі потреби військову силу.
Протистояння між могутніми
Америкою та Китаєм неминуче.
Керівництво Китаю рішуче налаштоване показати,
що держава перебуває у ліпшому становищі,
ніж ліберальні демократії,
що вона може впроваджувати інновації
та виробляти нові технології ефективніше.
Аби краще впливати на суспільство та боротися з кризами
Мао заснував Народну Республіку,
Сі хоче довести її до небувалих розмірів.
Китайське століття - ось історична місія Сі.
З нами на зв'язку Ульф Реллер з Пекіну, добрий вечір.
Напруга між Китаєм і США зростає.
Що очікувати від ситуації довкола Тайваню?
Насправді варто готуватися до тривалої напруженості,
незважаючи на окремі візити політиків.
Йдеться про фундаментальне суперництво,
новий світовий лад,
неврегульовані відносини між Китаєм і Америкою.
Американці мали свої політичні задвірки
в Латинській Америці на Близькому Сході,
де жорстоко відстоювали свої інтереси.
Китайці звинувачують нас у тому,
що Південнокитайське море є сферою їхнього впливу.
Це означає, що буде війна, але я не впевнений.
Китайська модель процвітає
за рахунок організації економічного успіху для свого населення.
Якщо це не спрацює, модель під загрозою.
Напруга зростає,
але вона не відразу
призведе до військового протистояння.
Ульфе, це твій останній репортаж з Китаю,
незабаром ти виходитимеш з нами на зв'язок з Брюсселя.
Ми хочемо скористатися цією можливістю,
щоб запитати тебе про головні події.
Що відбувається в Китаї
і до чого нам усім доведеться пристосовуватися?
За цей час відбулися дві визначні події.
Перша - вуличний протест у Гонконгу, в якому взяли участь
два млн жителів,
що скандували «Боротьба за свободу»
та обставали за свої права.
Це мене дуже зворушило та вразило.
Мені також довелося побачити, як ефективно та вміло
диктатура Китаю обплутала тенетами рух за свободу.
Крові не було, але людей поступово заарештовували.
Тепер Гонконг - цвинтар, де поховали громадянські права.
Другою ж визначною подією була пандемія COVID-19.
Спершу уряд Китаю, ймовірно, врятував країну
від занурення у вир хаосу жорстокими заходами, ізоляцією.
Але за останні два роки вони не використали можливість
вакцинувати все населення
або ж привезти західні ефективніші вакцини.
Певно, вони не зробили це з гордості.
А тепер їм доводиться реалізувати
безжалісну стратегію «нульової терпимості» до COVID-19,
що ставить під загрозу економічну ситуацію в країні.
Додам ще особистий коментар:
жити в країні, де панує диктатура, не завжди легко:
панує атмосфера контролю, а іноді й страху.
Але неабияк важливим, принаймні для мене, було те,
що я навчився розрізняти державний апарат та людей,
які є справді чудовими.
Китайці не дуже відрізняються від нас.
Вони також хочуть трохи щастя, трохи добробуту,
хочуть, щоб у їхніх дітей все було добре.
І з цими знаннями я рухаюсь далі з вдячністю.
Красно дякую за враження та аналіз, Ульфе.
Ми нетерпляче чекаємо на ваші репортажі з Європи.
Щиро дякую.
А зараз перейдемо до іншої теми.
Побоювання щодо нестачі енергії восени та взимку
зараз затьмарюють питання коронавірусу.
Але яка ж ситуація з коронавірусом?
Не так просто визначити,
якою зараз є кількість захворювань на COVID-19 в Німеччині.
Це також пов'язано з тим,
що багато людей не проходять тестування,
принаймні офіційно,
і тому статистика офіційних випадків
не є всеохопною.
Інші країни, як-от Швейцарія, Нідерланди,
Бельгія та Австрія,
вже давно встановили ефективні системи моніторингу
стічних вод.
У такий спосіб можна дізнатися, наприклад,
чи поширюються нові варіанти вірусу,
чи загрожує нова хвиля пандемії.
В Німеччині ці системи ще на стадії пілотного проєкту.
Детальніше про розробку цих систем у Штутґарті
розповість Єва Шиллер.
Штутґарт вже давно вважає моніторинг стічних вод
надійним джерелом інформації з поширення вірусу.
Працівники станцій очищення стічних вод
беруть проби шість разів на день,
а у лабораторії за допомогою ПЛР-тестів визначають
щоденне вірусне навантаження COVID-19.
Аналіз стічних вод має величезну перевагу
перед офіційною статистикою.
Максимум чотири години потрібно, аби доставити зразки
зі Штутґарта до нашої станції очищення стічних вод,
тому ми можемо взяти пробу, перевірити її
та використати перевагу у часі.
Передусім завдяки завзяттю керівника лабораторії
Петера Шиллінга
тест, який проводили в польових умовах,
став системою раннього попередження.
Його дані показують, що початок кожної хвилі коронавірусу
можна було передбачити на тиждень раніше
за результатами аналізу стічних вод.
І ось тепер, коли дедалі менше людей
проходять тестування,
ця станція надає департаменту охорони здоров'я
щоденну статистику щодо ситуації з COVID-19.
Спершу підвищуються показники саме в стічних водах,
тому це вважається системою раннього попередження.
У такому разі ми швидко інформуємо
всі інші організації.
Подальші заходи визначають залежно від інших параметрів.
Наприклад, від того, наскільки завантажені лікарні тощо.
З березня в Штутґарті та інших містах
проводять загальнодержавне пілотне дослідження.
Але результати мають отримати лише у 2023 році.
Водночас багато інших країн, як-от Швейцарія, Австрія,
Велика Британія,
вже давно покладаються на моніторинг стічних вод.
У Швейцарії проби зі 100 очисних споруд
нині дозволяють контролювати ситуацію
серед 70% населення.
Йдеться не лише про моніторинг ситуації з захворюваністю,
а й про виявлення нових варіантів.
Ми показали, що нам вдалося виявити ці варіанти
у стічних водах на два тижні раніше.
Зрозуміло, що це є чудовим
та економічно ефективним способом
отримання інформації щодо коронавірусу.
Я думаю, мало що може заперечити доцільність цього.
Вірусолог Мартін Штюрмер вважає,
що Німеччина втрачає нагоду,
особливо з огляду на те, що попереду осінь.
У нашій країні бракує саме практичної реалізації.
Варто зауважити, що ми надто придивлялися
і надто багато хотіли випробувати самостійно,
замість того, щоб послуговуватися досвідом інших,
що, можливо, дозволило б нам швидше почати
застосовувати цей метод.
Ми запитали у Міністра охорони здоров'я,
чому це триває так довго.
Ми запізно створюємо системи моніторингу стічних вод.
Але ми вже починаємо, системи наявні
вже у понад 20 містах.
Проте наразі ми не можемо використовувати цей спосіб
для моніторингу ситуації з захворюваністю
у всій країні.
Тож ми тільки випробовуємо його.
Керівник лабораторії Петер Шиллінг хотів би,
щоб кожна станція очищення, яка має власну лабораторію,
швидко і без бюрократичної тяганини надавала
своєму місту дані із стану стічних вод.
Адже приклад Штутґарта показує:
все може бути досить просто,
якщо хтось виявить ініціативу.
А зараз - огляд спортивних успіхів,
яких, крім Чемпіонату Європи з футболу серед жінок,
було вдосталь. Ґундуло, тобі слово.
У першому раунді Кубка Німеччини з футболу
команди Бундесліги, за винятком клубу «Герта»,
виправдали очікування та без проблем виграли свої матчі.
Йдеться про клуби «Шальке 04», «Гоффенгайм 1899»,
«Фрайбург»
та про клуб «Боруссія Менхенгладбах»,
яка в гостях забила дев'ять голів.
Аугсбург також пройшов у 2-й основний раунд,
як і «Майнц 04».
Берлінський клуб «Герта» вибув з Кубку,
програвши серію післяматчевих пенальтіклубу «Айнтрахт».
Крістофер Нкунку став першим професіоналом
клубу «РБ Лейпциг»,
який здобув звання «Футболіста року» в Німеччині.
Французький бомбардир із невеликим відривом
випередив ексфутболіста «Баварії» Роберта Левандовського
у голосуванні журналістів, організованому
журналом kicker.
«Тренером року» став Крістіан Штрайх -
головний тренер СК «Фрайбург» протягом десятиріччя.
А «Футболісткою року» стала гравчиня збірної Німеччини
Леа Шуллер,
новоспечена віцечемпіонка Європи
з ФК «Баварія» (Мюнхен).
Чемпіон світу з автоперегонів у класі «Формула-1»
Макс Ферстаппен
виграв Гран-прі Угорщини.
Нідерландець з команди Red Bull Racing
стартував з 10-го місця та випередив своїх суперників,
здобувши 8-му перемогу в 13-й перегонах сезону.
Другим та третім фінішували пілоти Mercedes
Льюїс Гамільтон і Джордж Расселл.
Себастьян Феттель фінішував 10-тим,
Мік Шумахер - 14-тим.
Ще один тріумф нідерландців.
Аннемік ван Влетен стала переможницею
першого в історії жіночого «Тур де Франс».
У велотурі, що проходив у горах Вогези, у Франції,
39-річна олімпійська чемпіонка
перегонів з роздільним стартом
фінішувала першою та захистила «Жовту майку»,
яку вона отримала вчора.
Її землячка Демі Воллерінг посіла друге місце
на останньому етапі та у загальному заліку.
Ліан Ліпперт фінішувала 14-ою, забезпечивши
найкращий результат серед інших німців та німкень.
Наступного тижня також відбудеться багато
не лише спортивних подій.
Як і щонеділі, зараз - огляд новин наступного тижня.
В Австрії з 1 серпня скасовують обов'язкову ізоляцію
у разі захворювання на коронавірус.
Міністерство охорони здоров'я повідомляє,
що інфікованим, які почуваються здоровими,
дозволятиметься виходити з дому та працювати.
Проте є певні обмеження, як-от обов'язок носити маску
в приміщенні
та заборона відвідувати лікарні й будинки
для людей похилого віку.
У понеділок Європейський суд має винести вирок
у справі німецьких рятувальних суден Sea-Watch 3
та Sea-Watch 4.
Йдеться про питання, чи мала влада Італії право
заарештовувати судна у сицилійських портах у 2020 році.
Оскільки судна рятують мігрантів,
організація Sea-Watch звинувачує Італію
в політичних намірах.
Президент РФ Володимир Путін
та президент Туреччини Реджеп Ердоган
знову зустрінуться у п'ятницю в місті Сочі.
Крім Сирії, на порядку денному, мабуть, й Україна.
Туреччина нещодавно стала
посередницею у конфлікті
та обставала за відновлення експорту українського зерна.
А в п'ятницю Бундесліга відкриває новий сезон
матчем франкфуртського клубу «Айнтрахт»,
чинного переможця Ліги Європи,
проти рекордного чемпіона - мюнхенського клубу «Баварія».
Таким був огляд від Зімони Фрідріх.
Погода в перший тиждень серпня буде
здебільшого сухою та спекотною.
Завтра лише на сході та в центрі
очікується густа хмарність, зливи та грози.
В інших регіонах сподіваємося на більше сонця, але по обіді
на півдні подекуди пройдуть грози.
Температура становитиме 18-31°С.
У вівторок переважно сонячно, 22-32°С.
У середу сонячно та дуже спекотно, до 37°С.
Спека очікується й у четвер, а на північному заході
йтимуть грози.
На цьому ми завершимо сьогоднішній випуск.
О 00:30 в ефірі будуть наші колеги з редакції «heute».
А ми побачимося з вами завтра. До побачення.
Гарного вечора.